MIKE POMPEO, AND HERE IS TUCKER
AND "TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT"."
♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ANYONE CAN SEE THAT JOE BIDEN
ISN’T AS QUICK AS HE USED TO BE,
IT TAKES THEM AN HOUR AND AND I
TO WATCH 60 MINUTES.
BUT WE ARE LESS THAN A WEEK IN
AND THE WHITE HOUSE HAS ALREADY
ENDED IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT,
SENT AMERICAN TROOPS INTO ARMED
CONFLICT, CRIPPLED THE LAST
REMAINING INFANT SECTOR OF OUR
ECONOMY AND OFFICIALLY FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN HUMAN HISTORY DENY
THE REALITY OF DIFFERENCES.
CONGRESS IS ABOUT TO GET
INVOLVED IN CHANGING THIS AND
DEMOCRATS CONTROL THE ENTIRE
LEGISLATIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
THEIR PRIORITY IS HOUSE
RESOLUTION NUMBER ONE.
IT’S CALLED THAT BECAUSE IT IS
THE FIRST BILL IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PIPELINE.
SO WHAT EXACTLY IS IN THAT BILL?
IS POSSIBLE THAT CNN HASN’T
BROUGHT YOU ALL THE DETAILS YET,
THEY ARE TOO BUSY TRYING TO SAVE
THE COUNTRY FROM FORBIDDEN IDEAS
ON INTERNET CHAT ROOMS.
HERE’S WHAT NANCY PELOSI SAID
ABOUT HR ONE BACK IN OCTOBER.
>> WE HAD PLENTY OF WORK TO DO
IN THE JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION,
WILL BUILD INFRASTRUCTURE OF
AMERICA IN A GREENWAY AND MAKE
SURE HEALTH CARE IS AVAILABLE TO
ALL AMERICANS.
LOWER THE COST OF PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS, WE WILL LEARN TO HAVE HR
ONE RIGHT OFF THE BAT, BE ABOUT
CLEANER GOVERNMENT SO WE CAN
REDUCE THE ROLE OF BIG, DARK,
SPECIAL INTEREST MONEY.
>> Tucker: HR ONE IS ALL ABOUT
THAT BIG DARK SPECIAL INTEREST
MONEY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHY
NANCY PELOSI IS STILL USING THAT
TERM DARK AS A EUPHEMISM FOR BAD
BAD.
BUT WHATEVER, IT’S NANCY PELOSI
SO WE CAN BE SURE IT’S NOT
RACIST.
THE REAL QUESTION IS HOW THE
PARTY OF RUTHLESS MONOPOLY GETS
AWAY WITH FAKE TALKING POINTS
LIKE THAT.
THE ANSWER OF COURSE IS TO GET
AWAY WITH IT BECAUSE NO ONE
STOPS THEM.
THIS IS THE "FOR THE PEOPLE" ACT
HERE.
AS FOR THE PEOPLE, SO SHUT UP.
WHAT EXACTLY DOES THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY PLAN TO DO FOR
THE PEOPLE?
IF YOU GUESSED ENSHRINED FOREVER
THEN YOU WIN THE DAILY DOUBLE.
THE "FOR THE PEOPLE ACT AS A
FOUNDATION OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY STRATEGY TO
CONTROL THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WELL INTO YOUR GRANDCHILDREN’S
MIDDLE AGE.
TAKE A LOOK AT IT.
LIKE MOST REVOLUTIONARY
DOCUMENTS, IT’S NOT A VERY
EXCITING READ NOTHING SOUNDS
ESPECIALLY RADICAL AT FIRST.
THE BILL BEGINS BY DECLARING
THAT CONTRARY TO ARTICLE ONE OF
THE UNITED STATES CAN’T
CONSTITUTION, CONGRESS HAS AN
"ULTIMATE SUPERVISORY POWER OVER
FEDERAL ELECTIONS.
UNDER OUR CURRENT LOSS, STATES
GET TO DECIDE HOW MUCH THEY GET
TO TOLERATE.
CALIFORNIA JUST WANTS YOU TO
VOTE DEMOCRAT.
IF HR ONE PASSES ALL 50 STATES
WILL BE CALIFORNIA AND THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY WILL HAVE VALID
HARVESTING AND MAIL-IN VOTING.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
ON JANUARY 6TH, WE HAD A RIOT AT
THE U.S. CAPITOL.
IT HAPPENED BECAUSE MILLIONS
WERE CONVINCED THE LAST ELECTION
WAS NOT FAIR.
WHERE DID THEY GET THE IDEA?
IT WASN’T BECAUSE THE LAST
PRESIDENT TOLD HIM SO.
YOU ARE HEARING THAT NOW AS IF
THEY ARE ANIMALS, BUT THEY SAW
THE RADICAL INCREASE IN MAIL-IN
VOTING.
MILLIONS DEAD.
AND IT CORRODED THEIR FAITH IN
THE PUBLIC’S FAITH IN OUR OF
ELECTIONS.
THEY WERE ENRAGED BY THAT AND
SOME OF THEM EXPLODED.
ACCORDING TO THE DEMOCRATS THE
LESSON OF THAT TERRIBLE DAY WAS
THAT WE NEEDED MORE OF THE
CORRUPT POLICIES THAT CAUSED IT
IN THE FIRST PLACE.
WE NEEDED MORE CORRUPTION, AND
THAT WILL UNITE THE COUNTRY.
HR ONE WOULD LITERALLY ENSHRINED
FRAUD.
HERE WAS A DIRECT QUOTE FROM
THAT LEGISLATION.
A STATE MAY NOT REQUIRE AN
INDIVIDUAL TO PROVIDE ANY FORM
OF IDENTIFICATION AS A CONDITION
OF OBTAINING AN ABSENTEE BALLOT.
ANY FORM OF IDENTIFICATION.
NOR CAN SIGNATURES BE VALIDATED.
HERE’S ANOTHER DIRECT QUOTE FROM
HR ONE.
"A STATE MAY NOT REQUIRE
NOTARIZATION OR WITNESS
SIGNATURE OR OTHER FORMAL
AUTHENTICATION AS A DIVISION OF
OBTAINING CASTING AN ABSENTEE
BALLOT.
UNDER HR ONE, THEY COULD FREELY
GO HOUSE TO HOUSE AND APARTMENT
TO APARTMENT COLLECTING UNKNOWN
THOUSANDS OF BALLOTS AND THEN
DUMP THEM ALL OUT OF BALLOT DROP
BOX.
NO ONE WOULD HAVE ANY IDEA IF
THOSE BALLOTS HAD BEEN TAMPERED
WITH AT ANY POINT ALONG THE WAY
OR WOULD THERE BE ANY WAY TO
PROVE IT IF THEY HAD BEEN
TAMPERED WITH.
HR ONE ALSO MAKES IT HARDER FOR
ELECTION OBSERVERS TO FILE
COMPLAINTS ABOUT ANY OF THIS
BECAUSE COMPLAINING IS RACIST.
A SYSTEM LIKE THAT IS SUICIDAL
FOR DEMOCRACY AND NO OTHER FREE
COUNTRY WOULD TOLERATE IT.
FRANCE AND CANADA WON’T TOLERATE
IT, THEY BANNED MAIL-IN BALLOTS.
THEY DON’T WANT FRAUD.
BY THE WAY, NEITHER IS
Amazon.com.
MAIL-IN VOTING ALLOWS HIS
PARTIES TO TAKE CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING AND YOU ARE A BIGOT
IF YOU OPPOSE THAT.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO UNION
ELECTIONS IN HIS OWN COMPANY,
ELECTIONS THAT MIGHT ALLOW
JEFF BEZOS TO PAY HIS -- AND
THEY WOULDN’T BE UNDER QUOTING
VALID VALID AND FAIR.
WHEN IT’S THEIR POWER AT STAKE
DEMOCRATS HAVE A TOTALLY
DIFFERENT POSITION AND THAT’S
TRUE IN CALIFORNIA.
YOU MAY HAVE HEARD THERE WAS A
RECALL EFFORT UNDERWAY IN THAT
AND THEY WERE TRYING TO BOOST
THEIR COMICALLY DEPENDENT
GOVERNOR’S SON.
IT’S NOT SO EASY TO GET IT DONE
BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE REQUIRING
IN PERSON SIGNATURES PETITIONS.
SUDDENLY THEY ARE VERY WORRIED
ABOUT VOTER FRAUD.
YOU SHOULD KNOW THIS IS NOT
CONSIDERED HYPOCRISY.
THEY DON’T MIND IF THEY ARE
CAUGHT BREAKING THEIR OWN RULES,
THEY ARE NOT OFFENDED BY DOUBLE
STANDARDS.
THEY WANT POWER, THIS IS A POWER
GRAB AND THAT’S ALL IT IS.
YOU’RE COMPLAINING ABOUT IT
MEANS NOTHING TO THEM.
IF YOU NEEDED MORE EVIDENCE OF
THAT, AS IF YOU NEEDED MORE
EVIDENCE, CONSIDERING HIS
LEGISLATION BY STEPHANIE MURPHY,
A DEMOCRAT FROM ORLANDO.
MURPHY HAS PROPOSED A BILL THAT
WOULD BAN ANYONE WITH THE WRONG
OPINIONS FROM HAVING A
SIGNIFICANT JOB IN THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
BELIEVE FORBIDDEN THINGS AND YOU
DON’T GET A SECURITY CLIENTS.
YOU CAN’T WORK HERE.
MURPHY’S BILL WOULD REQUIRE
FEDERAL INVESTIGATORS TO ASK ALL
APPLICANTS WHETHER THEY HAD
"ASSOCIATED WITH OR KNOWINGLY
ENGAGED IN ACTIVITIES CONDUCTED
BY AN ORGANIZATION OR MOVEMENT
THAT SPREADS CONSPIRACY THEORIES
AND FALSE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT."
WAIT A SECOND.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND FALSE
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT?
IT SOUNDS LIKE THESE PEOPLE
COULD BE IN TROUBLE.
>> YOU CAN SEE EVIDENCE IN PLAIN
SIGHT ON THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION.
>> I SAW THIS CLEAR EVIDENCE ON
THE ISSUE OF COLLUSION AND THIS
ADDS TO THE BODY OF EVIDENCE.
>> THERE IS SIGNIFICANT EVIDENCE
OF COLLUSION, AMPLE EVIDENCE AND
INDEED THERE IS.
I THINK THERE’S PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION OR
CONSPIRACY.
>> ALL OF THIS IS EVIDENCE OF
COLLUSION.
>> THERE IS SIGNIFICANT
EVIDENCE, MUCH OF IT IN THE
PUBLIC DOMAIN ON THE ISSUE OF
COLLUSION.
>> JUST KIDDING.
PEOPLE WHO SPENT YEARS PEDDLING
LUDICROUS CONSPIRACY THEORIES
THIS PROVED FACTUALLY, THESE
PEOPLE WILL BE FINE.
AT THIS POINT IT WOULD INCLUDE
EVERYONE PRETTY MUCH CURRENTLY
IN POWER.
THAT HURT OUR COUNTRY, BUT THIS
IS DESIGNED TO PROTECT THEM FROM
CRITICISM.
UNDER STEPHANIE MURPHY’S BILL
ANYONE WHO CRITICIZES
STEPHANIE MURPHY COULD BE
PUNISHED.
ACCENTS NOW?
NOW YOU THINK ALL OF THIS MIGHT
RAISE SOME EYEBROWS AMONG
TRADITIONAL CIVIL LIBERTIES
PEOPLE OR CIVIL LIBERTIES FOLKS
AS THEY CALL THEM.
BUT IT’S 2021.
LAWS LIKE THIS ARE DIRECTLY AT
THE MEDIA SWORN ARCHENEMIES,
PEOPLE WHO WENT TO STATE SCHOOLS
AND OTHER UNDESIRABLES.
LISTEN TO THE GENE COMIC
GENIUSES EXPLAIN.
THIS IS PRETTY MUCH A CERTAINTY
NOW WHICH WAS 100% CAUSED BY
ELITE MISMANAGEMENT OF OUR
ECONOMY.
BUT LET’S NOT TALK ABOUT THAT.
THE REAL THREAT IS A FORBIDDEN
IDEA.
>> NEXT, WHAT TO DO ABOUT QANON
AND ITS TROVES OF LOWER, LOYAL
FOLLOWERS.
IS IT TOO LATE TO BRING OUR
LOVED ONES BACK TO REALITY?
>> MANY WHO BELIEVE THE
UNFOUNDED CONSPIRACIES AND
PROPHECIES EXPECTED JANUARY 20TH
TO BE JUDGMENT DAY.
>> IS FAR RIGHT FIGURES ARE
JOINED BY OTHERS.
>> HOW MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COUNTRY HAVE BEEN MARINATED IN
THESE CONSPIRACY THEORIES, AND
IT IS FRIGHTENING.
>> Tucker: MR. TOM FRIEDMAN
THINKS THIS IS PRETTY
FRIGHTENING AND HE’S RIGHT.
BUT WATCHING A PROFOUND CHANGE
TAKING PLACE IN AMERICAN
SOCIETY, AND IT’S HAPPENING
FAST.
THE STAKES COULD NOT BE HIGHER.
THERE’S A CLEAR LINE BETWEEN
DEMOCRACY AND TYRANNY, BETWEEN
SELF-GOVERNMENT AND DICTATORSHIP
AND HERE’S WHAT THAT LINE IS.
THAT LINE IS YOUR CONSCIENCE.
THEY CANNOT CROSS THAT.
GOVERNMENT HAS EVERY RIGHT TO
TELL YOU WHAT TO DO, AND
CONTROLLING THE BEHAVIOR OF
CITIZENS IS ONE OF THE BASIC
PREROGATIVES OF ANY ORGANIZED
SOCIETY.
THEY CAN PREVENT YOU FROM
COMMITTING MURDER OR RATE OR
SPEED WALKING OR JAYWALKING,
THAT’S ALL ALLOWED.
BUT NO DEMOCRATIC GOVERNMENT CAN
EVER TELL YOU WHAT TO THINK.
YOUR MIND BELONGS TO YOU, IT’S
YOURS AND YOURS ALONE.
ONCE POLITICIANS ATTEMPT TO
CONTROL WHAT YOU BELIEVE THEY
ARE NO LONGER POLITICIANS.
THEY ARE BY DEFINITION
DICTATORS.
IF THEY SUCCEED AND CONTROLLING
WHAT YOU BELIEVE THEN YOU ARE NO
LONGER A CITIZEN.
YOU ARE NOT A FREE MAN, YOU ARE
A.
SO YES TOM FRIEDMAN, IT’S
FRIGHTENING.
IT’S EVERYWHERE ALL OF A SUDDEN
AND NO ONE IS PUSHING BACK.
SO JOIN THE MOB OF THE SENSOR IS
IN HYSTERICS AND DESTROYERS ARE
WORKING ON BEHALF OF ENTRENCHED
POWER TO TAKE TOTAL CONTROL OF
EVERYTHING.
OVERSTATEMENT?
NO IT’S NOT.
THE NEW IDEA IS THIS CHANNEL
SHOULD NOT BE ALLOWED.
THEY ARE NOT ARGUING THAT
FOX NEWS IS INACCURATE AND
DISHONEST AND YOU SHOULDN’T
WATCH IT, THEY ARE ARGUING THAT
YOU SHOULDN’T BE ABLE TO WATCH
FOX NEWS BECAUSE FOX SHOULD BE
ELIMINATED BY FORCE.
A FEW DAYS AGO A COLUMNIST
POSTED THIS QUESTION
ON TWITTER."
SHOULD FOX NEWS BE ALLOWED TO
EXIST?
NO, HE QUICKLY CONCLUDED.
FOX NEWS SHOULDN’T BE LEGAL.
ONE SEEMED TO BE SURPRISED BY
THIS.
CNN CERTAINLY AGREES WITH THAT
AND CNN AS OF OUR DIRECT
COMPETITOR OF COURSE SO YOU
MIGHT IMAGINE HE WOULD RECUSE
THEMSELVES FROM THIS
CONVERSATION.
BUT JUST THE OPPOSITE, CNN IS
STARING DOWN SOME PRETTY LEAN
RATINGS AND THEY WOULD LOVE ONE
LESS ON THE DIAL.
THEY TURN THEM LOOSE TO EXPLAIN
THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWING PEOPLE TO
WATCH WHAT THEY WANT TO WATCH ON
TV IS A METHOD THREAT TO
DEMOCRACY.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN SEEMS TO
UNDERSTAND, AND ALL OF THESE AND
ALL THAT HAS CAUSED THE SEPARATE
REALITIES IN UNITED STATES.
>> IT REMAINS A THREAT TO OUR
DEMOCRACY AND IT’S THE REASON
WHY THERE ARE HUNDREDS OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER’S STORM IN THE CAPITAL
CAPITAL.
AND I DO THINK THAT THESE FORCES
REPRESENT AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT
TO THIS COUNTRY.
>> NO ONE HAS EVER BEEN ASKED TO
USE SPELL THE WORD EXISTENTIAL.
HE HAS EXPRESSED AND THAT IS
THAT’S TOO MUCH CHOICE, THAT’S
NOT DEMOCRATIC.
"CORPORATIONS THAT ADVERTISE ON
FOX NEWS SHOULD WALK AWAY.
AND CITIZENS WHO CARE ABOUT THE
TRIP SHOULD DEMAND THAT THEY DO
SO.
AGAIN, MARGARET SULLIVAN DIDN’T
ASK PEOPLE TO STOP WATCHING
FOX NEWS, SHE ASKED FOR US TO BE
UNEMPLOYED.
HER COLLEAGUE AGREED WITH THAT.
MAX BOOT ALSO LABORS FOR
JEFF BEZOS UP THE
"WASHINGTON POST."
WHEN YOU WORK FOR THE WORLD’S
RICHEST MAN, PEOPLE TEND TO
LISTEN TO YOU.
WHEN YOU CALL FOR GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS TO CRUSH DISSENT,
THAT’S NOT A A SMALL THING.
>> I THINK THERE’S ALSO THE
POSSIBILITY OF REVIVING THE
FAIRNESS DOCTRINE IN WHICH
MANDATED SOME MINIMAL STANDARDS
OF FOR ACTUALITY AND BALANCE ON
THE PART OF TV STATIONS AND
SINCE THAT DISAPPEARED IT, IT’S
A COMPLETE FREE-FOR-ALL WITH ALL
SORTS OF LUNACY BEING FIT
DIRECTLY INTO THE RIGHT WING
ECHO SYSTEM.
>> THE FAIRNESS DOCTRINE DOES
NOT ONLY APPLY TO CABLE NEWS
SINCE THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
DOESN’T OWN THE CABLE LINES BUT
WHAT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER IS THE
IDEA THAT MAX BOOT JUST
EXPLAINED THAT IT IS "UNFAIR"
FOR ONE NEWS OUTLET FOR EVERY
OTHER NEWS OUTLET.
SAYING IT’S UNFAIR SHOULD BE
MANDATORY, AND THAT’S WHY IT’S
INCLUSIVE.
IN ADDITION TO EVERYTHING ELSE,
THESE PEOPLE ARE STUPID.
THAT’S WHY OUR COUNTRY IS IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE THE PEOPLE WHO
RUN THE COUNTRY CAN’T FIND
THINGS WITH BOTH HANDS.
NO SELF-RESPECTING LANDSCAPE
COMPANY WOULD HAVE MAX BOOT.
BUT THAT DOESN’T MEAN HE WON’T
WIN.
IT’S A MISTAKE TO IMAGINE THAT
SIMPLY BECAUSE AN IDEA IS WRONG
OR STUPID OR IMMORAL THAT IT
CANNOT PREVAIL, AT LEAST FOR A
WHILE.
OF COURSE IT CAN PREVAIL.
HISTORY IS FILLED WITH EXAMPLES
OF THIS.
NEW COKE WAS A REAL BEVERAGE.
WE SHOULD BE WORRIED AND THEY
DEFINITELY ARE SAYING THEM.
JOE SCARBOROUGH HAS A MORNING
SHOW ON MSNBC AND JOE
SCARBOROUGH ISN’T STUPID HARDLY.
LOOK UP ANIMAL CUNNING
DICTIONARY AND YOU WILL FIND HIS
PICTURE.
WHAT JOE SCARBOROUGH IS, IS A
HERD ANIMAL.
FLEXIBLE.
IF ALL THE KIDS ARE DOING IT, HE
WANTS A SEAT ON THE BUS.
WHEN PEOPLE APPEAR ON FOX NEWS
THEY NEED TO BE FORCED TO SHUT
UP IMMEDIATELY.
>> FOX NEWS HAD SOMEONE I KNOW,
A FORMER LEADER OF THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY SAYING THAT
DEMOCRATS WANTED, AND I’M USING
HIS WORDS HERE, DEMOCRATS WANTED
TO "EXTERMINATE.
EXTERMINATE ALL REPUBLICANS.
LET ME SAY THAT AGAIN FOR
FOX NEWS SPONSORS SO THAT YOU
KNOW, FOR FOX NEWS SPONSORS, TO
LET YOU KNOW WHAT’S HAPPENING
NOW ON FOX NEWS.
THEY ARE GETTING PEOPLE WHO ARE
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR’S WHO ARE
SAYING THAT DEMOCRATS, JOE BIDEN
AND DEMOCRATS WANT TO"
EXTERMINATE" ALL REPUBLICANS.
>> Tucker: I’M SAYING THIS FOR
FOX NEWS SPONSORS.
SO HOW HONEST DO YOU WANT TO BE
HERE?
THE MENU JUST JUST SAW HAS BEEN
ACCUSED BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF MURDERING A
YOUNG WOMAN.
WE ARE NOT TAKING A POSITION ON
JOE SCARBOROUGH’S GUILT OR
INNOCENCE ON THAT CASE, WE ARE
NOT A LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY AND
IT’S NOT OUR PLACE TO DO THAT.
BUT ONE THING WE DID NOT DO AND
WOULD NEVER DO IS GO ON TV AND
DEMANDS THAT BECAUSE JOE
SCARBOROUGH WAS ACCUSED OF
VIOLENCE BY A POLITICIAN,
AMERICAN COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE
ALLOWED TO SELL THEIR PRODUCTS
TO HIS VIEWERS.
THAT NEVER OCCURRED TO US, NOT
EVEN FOR A SECOND.
WE ARE NOT FASCIST OR
MIDDLE-AGED PERFORMERS RUNNING
AWAY FROM THEIR OWN CONSCIOUS.
WE ARE AMERICAN.
WE THINK PEOPLE WE DISAGREE WITH
SHOULD STILL BE ALLOWED TO TALK
IN PUBLIC.
THEY HAVE NEVER BELIEVED THAT,
THEY ARE GLOBAL CONGLOMERATES CO
AND THEY ARE MORE POWERFUL THAN
OUR GOVERNMENT.
LAST WEEK ON CNN THE FORMER
CHIEF SECURITY OFFICER AT
FACEBOOK -- HOW DOES THAT TITLE
STRIKE YOU?
A MAN CALLED ALEX STAMOS, SAID
THIS.
>> IT’S REALLY HARD BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO SEEK OUT
INFORMATION THAT MAKES THEM FEEL
GOOD.
PEOPLE HAVE SO MUCH CHOICE NOW,
THEY CAN CHOOSE WHETHER USE
SOURCES ARE AND THEY CAN CHOOSE
WHAT INFLUENCERS THEY WANT TO
FOLLOW.
THERE ARE PEOPLE ON YOUTUBE FOR
EXAMPLE THAT HAVE A LARGER
AUDIENCE THAN DAYTIME CNN AND
THEY ARE EXTREMELY RADICAL IN
PUSHING EXTREMELY RADICAL VIEWS.
>> Tucker: SO IN THE NAME OF
DEMOCRACY WHICH IS CLEARLY THE
TERM OF THE MOMENT, IN DEFENSE
OF THE PEOPLE’S WILL MUST CENSOR
PEOPLE AND MAKE CERTAIN THAT
INDIVIDUALS CAN’T READ AND HEAR
WHAT THEY CHOOSE TO READ AND
HEAR.
AT LEAST THEY ARE BEING HONEST
ABOUT IT.
INFORMATION IS POWER AND THEY
WANT THE POWER SO THEREFORE THEY
MUST CONTROLLED INFORMATION, SO
THEY ARE.
THAT’S WHAT’S HAPPENING.
WE TOLD YOU A MOMENT AGO THAT
NOBODY SEEMS TO BE FIGHTING BACK
AGAINST THIS TIDE OF OPPRESSION.
RUPERT MURDOCH WON AN AWARD FROM
THE FOUNDATION IN THE U.K. AND
HERE IS PART OF WHAT HE SAID
WHEN HE ACCEPTED.
"FOR THOSE OF US IN THE MEDIA
THERE IS A REAL CHALLENGE TO
CONFRONT A WAVE OF CENSORSHIP
THAT SEEKS TO SILENCE
CONSERVATION, TO ULTIMATELY STOP
INDIVIDUALS AND SOCIETIES FROM
REALIZING THEIR POTENTIAL.
THIS RIGIDLY ENFORCED,
CONFORMITY IS A STRAITJACKET ON
SENSIBILITY.
TOO MANY PEOPLE HAVE FOUGHT TOO
HARD AND TOO MANY PLACES FOR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH TO BE
OPPRESSED BY THE AWFUL WOKE
ORTHODOXY.
THIS AWFUL WOKE ORTHODOXY.
WE DON’T QUOTE OUR BOSS OFTEN
COME EVER ON THE SHOW ACTUALLY,
THAT’S EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT’S PRECISELY WHAT THIS IS.
THERE’S NOTHING WORSE FOR THE
COUNTRY OR FOR JOURNALISM, EVERY
PUBLISHER OF EVERY OWNER SHOULD